Hallo und herzlich willkommen zu Raumzeit, dem Podcast über Raumfahrt und andere.
Kosmische Angelegenheiten.
Mein Name ist Tim Prittlaff und nach einer längeren Pause geht es jetzt wieder weiter bei Raumzeit.
Wir haben eine interessante Liste von Themen hier vorangestellt und die werden
jetzt hier Schritt für Schritt abgearbeitet, damit es hier demnächst mehr Raumzeit
gibt. Ja, und womit geht es los?
Heute hat mich der Weg nach Heidelberg geführt, hier war ich ja schon häufiger,
ist ein sehr ergiebiges Städtchen, muss man sagen, was so den ganzen Raumfahrt
und speziell den Astronomiebereich betrifft.
Konkret bin ich jetzt hier beim ARRI gelandet, dem Astronomischen Recheninstitut,
da hatten wir auch schon zweimal das Vergnügen mit Stefan Jordan.
Aber heute begrüße ich erstmal meinen heutigen Gesprächspartner,
nämlich den Markus. Markus Hundertmark. Hallo.
Hallo Tim, vielen Dank.
Herzlich willkommen bei Raumzeit. Ja, ihr habt es immer sehr schön hier, muss ich sagen.
Ja, das freut uns. Immer wieder gerne.
Ja, ja, also oft hat man ja so moderne Gebäude und so weiter und hier in Heidelberg
ist alles so richtig schön aus dem Bilderbuch. Das ist schön.
Ja, wir freuen uns immer wieder über die Stadt.
Und es ist auch touristisch sehr attraktiv. Die Kollegen besuchen uns sehr gerne aus vielen Gründen.
Oh, kann ich verstehen. Ja, ist ein Feature.
Besser als so, ja, kommt doch mal ins Gewerbegebiet. Ja, da kann man mit Heidelberg
auf jeden Fall schon mal was machen.
Auch der Standort oben auf dem Berg ist ja sehr schön. Wie heißt nochmal der Standort?
Das Königstuhl am Max-Planck-Institut oder das Haus der Astronomie.
Genau, das Haus der Astronomie. Das hatte ich gerade nicht mehr im Kopf.
Die Landesstandworte natürlich auch als Teil von unserem Zentrum.
Genau, und darauf wollte ich auch hinaus. Das Ganze ist ja sozusagen ein Teilinstitut
hier vom Zentrum für Astronomie bei der Universität Heidelberg.
Also hier wird jetzt nicht nur geforscht, sondern hier wird sozusagen auch gelehrt.
Und wie immer gehört das hier alles zusammen.
Ja, und das ARRI.
Ist ja, ich hatte das hier in den Sendungen mit Stefan Joran ja schon,
vor allem in diesem Gaia-Projekt extrem investiert.
Der Gaia-Katalog, der große Sternenkatalog wird unter anderem auch hier mit
bearbeitet und editiert.
Aber heute soll es um was ganz anderes gehen.
Heute wollen wir über das VERAC-Rubin Observatory, ein neues Teleskop in Chile sprechen.
Aber bevor wir das machen, fragen wir erstmal, was denn eigentlich deine Reise
durch den Kosmos so ausgelöst hat.
Wie bist du denn zu dieser Wissenschaft gekommen und was machst du heute?
Mikrogravitationslinseneffekt, das ist der Teil, oder das Arbeitsgebiet,
in dem ich tätig bin, schon 2006 gekommen, als Teil meiner Diplomarbeit in Göttingen
und habe da auch promoviert.
Und das hat mich tatsächlich unweigerlich auf diese Schiene gebracht.
Danach war ich in Schottland tätig, zusammen mit Partnern beim Las Cumbers Observatory,
mit dem wir auch heute noch zusammenarbeiten.
Das ist ein Observatorium, ein Netzwerk robotischer Teleskope,
die auf der gesamten Welt verteilt sind und die von ihrem Hauptquartier nahe
Santa Barbara aus kontrolliert werden.
Und in diesem Team bin ich seit 2006 tätig.
Danach habe ich eine kleine Detour über Kopenhagen gemacht, über das Nils-Bohr-Institut
und da an einem Teleskop in einer anderen Kollaboration auch zu Mikrolinsen geforscht.
Und der Schwerpunkt, den ich da hatte, der hat auch etwas unmittelbar mit Rubin zu tun.
Und zwar ging es da um die Datenauswertung mit der Differenzbildanalyse.
Und das ist genau auch das Rückgrat von den Veränderlichen, die Rubin berichten wird.
Und deswegen kann ich da auch ein bisschen was zu erzählen, wie es dann dazu
gekommen ist. Danach bin ich hier nach Heidelberg gekommen, um weiter in den
Kollaborationen zu arbeiten, aber für andere auch zusammen mit diesem Team, das heißt RoboNet.
Und es gibt es in verschiedenen Zusammensetzungen auch heute noch.
Wir verfolgen eben Mikrogravitationslinsenereignisse, also spezielle Ereignisse
am Himmel, die dafür sorgen, dass Sterne heller erscheinen im Laufe der Zeit
und wieder schwächer werden.
Und das ist ein statistisches Phänomen in der Milchstraße.
Und ein bisschen darüber hinaus, wir sagen galaktischer Mikrogravitationslinseneffekt
oder kurz Mikrolinseneffekt und wir suchen nach Linsen,
die vor anderen Hintergrundsternen vorziehen und diese Helligkeitsänderung auslösen.
Also ein Effekt der Gravitation, der ja den
den Raum krümmt und wenn sich was krümmt, wird halt auch das Licht gleich mitgekrümmt
und dadurch entstehen diese Linseneffekte.
Genau, das Licht wird abgelenkt und anstelle einfach ins Weltall zu divergieren
oder rauszulaufen, sorgt die Linse dafür, dass das Licht ein bisschen, sagen wir,
so pseudo angezogen wird und wie bei einem Brechungsindex zur Erde geleitet wird.
Es entstehen dabei mehrere Bilder, aber beim Mikrogravitationslinseneffekt ist
die Spezialität, dass die Bilder nicht aufgelöst werden können.
Zumindest nicht mit normalen Mitteln,
weil die Trennung in unserer Milchstraße so klein ist, dass man die Bögen,
die entstehen, von dem Hintergrundstern nicht sieht, aber die Fläche am Himmel ist größer.
Deswegen kommt mehr Licht an und deswegen wird es heller.
Man kennt diese Bögen auch aber nicht in unserer Milchstraße,
sondern wenn die Linsen ganze Galaxien und die Hintergrundobjekte auch ganze Galaxien sind,
im Hubble Space Teleskop, in tiefen Belichtungen, da sieht man tatsächlich diese Bögen am Himmel.
Das ist auch starker Gravitationslinseneffekt, aber der Mikrolinseneffekt,
der basiert darauf, dass wir wirklich nur die Helligkeit von einem Objekt verfolgen.
In diesem Pixel quasi oder in wenigen Pixeln sind diese Bilder drin und sorgen
einfach nur dafür, dass es heller wird. Und dieses Hellerwerden gibt uns...
Eine Methode, um eine Masse zu messen in einer gewissen Form.
Also mit anderen Worten, du suchst wörtlich Sterne mit der Lupe.
Ja, tatsächlich. Budan Paczynski, einer der absoluten Größen in diesem Feld,
hat tatsächlich für die Veränderung im Englischen das Wort Magnification geprägt.
Das heißt, wie mit dem Vergrößerungsglas, das ist nicht ganz falsch.
Nur die Art von Linse ist kein Vergrößerungsglas, sondern ich würde jetzt eher
sagen, das Weinglas, der Fuß vom Weinglas, um ganz genau zu sein.
Weil die Linsen, die wir sehen, die erzeugen mehrere Bilder und nicht so ein
Bild, wie wir es normalerweise mit einer Linse, mit einer Sammellinse von der
Lupo oder so sehen würden, sondern eben diese weinglasförmigen Bilder.
Und das kann man, vielleicht auch ohne es zu zerstören, sehen,
wenn man dann einen schwarzen Punkt auf einem Blatt Papier malt und das davor
hält, dann sieht man, wie dann zwei Bilder entstehen.
Jetzt kann man sich vorstellen, geht man ganz weit davon weg,
dann ist das quasi unsere Verstärkung, die wir sehen, die können wir nicht auflösen,
die ist in unseren Pixeln drin, die wir dann vermessen.
Wie bist du denn zu dem Thema gekommen und was fasziniert dich daran?
Tatsächlich war es ein Vorschlag von meinem damaligen Betreuer in Göttingen
von Rick Hesman, der die Monet-Teleskope, das sind zwei robotische Teleskope,
betreut hat und da viele Jahre federführend für verantwortlich war.
Und er hat das Thema vorgeschlagen und mich hat die Methode damals einfach fasziniert.
Und die Möglichkeit, die Objekte zu suchen, die sonst nicht findbar sind.
Das heißt, die Linsen, die wir finden, die müssen wir nicht sehen können.
Das ist das ganz Besondere.
Das heißt, wir müssen nur den Hintergrundstern sehen. Und was davor ist,
braucht nicht hell zu sein.
Und das ist eben auch das Einzigartige an dem Effekt.
Das können alle Objekte sein. Das können braune Zwerge sein,
die jetzt kaum leuchtstark sind.
Das können schwarze Löcher sein, auch isolierte schwarze Löcher,
die auch mit dieser Methode gefunden werden können, die sonst mit keiner anderen
Methode gefunden werden.
Und hoffnungsvollerweise auch
in Zukunft freifliegende, nicht gebundene Planetenmassen, sagen wir mal.
Also planetengroße Objekte, die nicht in einem Sonnensystem gebunden sind.
Freie, wie heißen die?
Ja, wir nennen die, es gibt verschiedene Ausdrücke dafür.
Freifliegende Planeten, sagen einige, Rogue Planets und so weiter.
Aber die Internationale Astronomische Union hat hier noch keine Definition.
Das heißt, wir würden technisch sagen, wahrscheinlich so etwas wie ungebundene
Objekte planetarer Masse und etwas in der Art. Das klingt nicht schön,
aber dann lieber die Free Floating Planets, FFPs, das klingt irgendwie greifiger.
Okay, ist noch Platz im Definitionsraum auf jeden Fall.
Ja, also man kann sozusagen mit dieser Technik jetzt nicht nur Sterne sich genauer
anschauen, sondern im Prinzip theoretisch auch Planeten erkennen.
Also von der Größe sozusagen, von der Massengröße. Die sind aber sehr klein,
wenn die so weit weg sind.
Das ist für uns kein Problem. Und wir müssen unsere Kollegen,
die mit anderen Methoden arbeiten, zum Beispiel mit der Transit-Methode,
die einfach nur Planeten bedeckt, wie wir das in unserem Sonnensystem auch kennen,
wenn die Venus vor der Sonne ist oder mit der Radialgeschwindigkeitsmethode,
der der erste Exoplanet gefunden wurde.
Diese Methoden vernachlässigen ganz häufig unseren Effekt, weil wir messen im
Prinzip keine Bahnperiode, sondern wir messen also was wie einen Abstand,
einen Schnappschuss, wo sich der Planet gerade befindet.
Und wenn der Planet sich in einem eigentlich projizierten Abstand zu dem jeweiligen
Mutterstern, sagen wir mal, befindet, dann können wir den detektieren und wir
brauchen auch da kein Licht für. Das kann auch ein sehr kleiner Planet sein.
Mit einem Mikrolinseneffekt können wir Verstärkungen erzielen und Muster,
die bei sobald mehrere Objekte ins Spiel kommen, die deutlich von der erwarteten
Helligkeitsschwankung dieser Kurve abweicht.
Und so kriegen wir so ein Massenverhältnis raus und wir kriegen ganz diesen projizierten Abstand.
Aber den können wir nicht ganz einfach in die Perioden, die die anderen Teams
berichten, umrechnen, sondern nur unter Annahmen.
Deswegen machen wir das ganz häufig nicht und wenn in diesem System von Exoplaneten
berichtet werden, sieht man die Mikro-Lensing-Planeten mehr als 250 im Moment.
Überhaupt nicht, aber es ist eine der Top-Beobachtungsmethoden und es wird auch
für uns ganz wichtig, für ein anderes Teleskop ganz wichtig werden,
das Nancy Grace Roman Space Telescope.
Wenn das fliegt, dann haben wir die große Hoffnung, dass für die Community,
also für die Mikro-Linsen-Community, ganz, ganz viele Planeten gefunden werden.
Ich vergleiche das immer, das ist unser Kepler.
Kepler hat für die Transit-Methode revolutioniert und wir hoffen,
dass das Nancy Grace Roman Space Telescope entsprechend auch die Planetensuche
bei uns revolutioniert und die Antwort auf die Frage nach den freifliegenden
Planeten auch beantworten kann.
Das ist ein Teleskop, was nach aktueller Planung schon in zwei Jahren,
ungefähr anderthalb Jahre starten soll.
So Mitte 2027 ein Infrarot-Weltraumteleskop der NASA.
So, aber wir bleiben jetzt erstmal auf der Erde, denn auch Bodenteleskope haben ja ihre Anwendung.
Und ich habe es ja eingangs schon erwähnt, wir wollen uns mit dem Vera Rubin Teleskop oder Vera C.
Rubin Teleskop oder Observatory unterhalten, benannt nach Vera C.
Rubin, die ja eine sehr bekannte astronomische Forscherin war,
die, glaube ich, vor allem zur dunklen Materie gearbeitet hat, richtig?
Ja, das ist Vera Cooper Rubin. Es war entscheidend bei der Entdeckung der dunklen
Materie Und zwar in den Rotationskurven von Galaxien.
Das heißt, zum ersten Mal haben ihr Mitarbeiter und sie einen neuen Spektrografen
zur Anwendung gebracht, der es ermöglicht hat, die Rotation von anderen Galaxien,
also nicht der Milchstraße, auszuwählen.
Aufzulösen und zu bestimmen, wie schnell dreht sich denn diese Scheibe.
Ist das mehr ein Karussell oder ist das etwas anderes?
Und man erwartet natürlich eine gewisse Kurve, aufgrund der Mechanik, wie wir sie kennen.
Und dann stellt man fest, dass dieses Abflachen der Kurve nicht eintritt,
sondern dass es in den Außenbereichen der Galaxien,
die Rotationskurve relativ hoch bleibt und die Geschwindigkeit relativ hoch.
Und daraus schließt man, okay, das funktioniert, wenn wir etwas Nichtleuchtendes einfügen.
Und dieses Nichtleuchtende zu diesem Zeitpunkt, das ist eben die dunkle Materie.
Und weil sie eben diese Pionierleistungen, diese ersten Beobachtungen dazu und
die Interpretationen erbracht hat, hat der amerikanische Kongress 2019 entschieden,
das Teleskop oder vielmehr nicht das Teleskop, sondern das Observatorium nach ihr zu benennen.
Und hier geht die Namensgebung los, die sich ein bisschen verändert hat im Laufe der Zeit.
Denn ursprünglich hatte das Projekt ja noch einen anderen Namen,
der sich mehr an der eigentlichen Aufgabe orientiert hat.
Also ich glaube Large Synoptic Survey Telescope.
Also da steckt ja so ein bisschen drin, was hier denn eigentlich getan wird.
Nämlich, dass es einerseits ein sehr großes Teleskop ist, aber das ist halt
ein synoptisch überwachbar, also sozusagen so eine holistische Betrachtung des
gesamten Himmels. Vielen Dank.
Ja, genau. Und das ist tatsächlich der, ich würde sogar sagen,
zweite Name. Aber das ist der, unter dem es die meiste Zeit bekannt ist.
Das heißt, der damalige Ausdruck Large Synoptic Survey Telescope spiegelt wieder,
was das Teleskop machen sollte. Aber tatsächlich geht die Geschichte noch ein bisschen eher los.
Das heißt, schon vor fast 30 Jahren wurden die ersten Überlegungen zu diesem Teleskop gemacht.
Und damals hatte man nicht daran gedacht, dass das verschiedene wissenschaftliche
Aspekte abdecken soll, sondern da ging es wirklich um die dunkle Materie als
Haupt-, als Dreh- und Angelpunkt und als das entscheidende Thema.
Und deswegen hieß es damals so Dark-Meter-Teleskop oder etwas in der Art.
Und dann wurde dann tatsächlich in den Decadal-Surveys in den USA,
werden alle zehn Jahre ein Bericht geschrieben,
der darstellt, wie die Astronomie sich im nächsten Jahrzehnt entwickeln soll,
welche Projekte wichtig sind, bodengebunden, Weltraum gebunden.
Und im Jahr 2010 war für die bodengebundene optische Astronomie das Viral-Sea-Rubin-Observatorium
oder LSST damals das wichtigste Projekt,
was die Fragestellung, die gelistet und die die Gemeinschaft dort zusammengestellt hat,
entsprechend auch widerspiegelt.
Und dann hat es noch ein bisschen gedauert, noch einmal vor zehn Jahren etwa,
war Baubeginn und nach zehn Jahren Bauzeit sind wir jetzt in diesem Jahr zu
den ersten Bildern mit der größten Kamera der Welt gekommen.
Ja, und es sieht, wie man so schön sagt, auch sehr spacig aus.
Kann ich nur von Fotos jetzt den Eindruck schildern. Vor Ort war ich leider nicht.
Steht auf einem dieser Berge im chilenischen Hochland auf dem Cerro Pachon.
Es ist beileibe nicht das einzige Teleskop, das ist glaube ich in unmittelbarer
Nähe, gibt es nochmal ein,
zwei andere, die noch zum selben Komplex dazugehören und drumherum alle 50 bis
100 Kilometer gibt es ja dann immer wieder so eine neue Gruppierung von Teleskopen,
die von den unterschiedlichsten Organisationen betrieben werden.
Sehr viel von der ESO, von den Amerikanern und weiß gar nicht,
wer sonst noch alles dort Teleskope betreibt.
Das ist also auf jeden Fall der Tummelplatz und das ist ja auch klar, warum.
Chilenische Bergwüste ideale Voraussetzungen hat für die Himmelsbeobachtung,
dadurch, dass durch diesen pazifischen kalten Strom die Feuchtigkeit einfach
so weggehalten wird, dass einfach nicht so viel Wasser in der Luft ist.
Ich richtig erinnere, ist das so im Wesentlichen der Faktor.
Mögen vielleicht noch ein paar andere dazukommen.
Ich denke mal, mittlerweile ist Chile halt auch einfach ein treuer Partner der
Wissenschaft geworden, so über die Jahrzehnte.
Ich meine, profitieren natürlich in gewisser Hinsicht auch von diesen ganzen Installationen.
Aber naja, ist ja auch ein Land, teilweise ein Aufruhr.
Trotzdem, warst du schon mal vor Ort irgendwann?
Ja, ich war zweimal in Chile auf
Beobachtungsläufen. Damals tatsächlich am dänischen Teleskop auf La Sia.
Zumindest die Stadt, die man zunächst zu dem Land aus Santiago de Chile fliegt,
ist die gleiche, wenn man das Rubin Observatory besuchen möchte oder eben das
ESO-Lasia Observatory,
dann wird man jedes Mal nach La Sarena fliegen und dann entsprechend per Bus
in der Regel oder per Shuttle, wie auch immer,
zu dem jeweiligen Teleskopen auf, ja meistens sind die zwischen 2.000 und 2.500
Metern ungefähr Höhe, dann hochfahren und sich dann dort langsam akklimatisieren,
Meistens eine halbe Nacht, um dann den Beobachtungslauf zu starten.
Das sind aber noch nicht die Höhen, wo man einen speziellen Test vorher machen muss, ne?
Da braucht man zum Glück noch keinen Test vorher. Aber es empfiehlt sich trotzdem,
vorher sich mal durchchecken zu lassen, um ganz sicher zu sein.
Ein bisschen Höhenkrankheit kann jeden erwischen und dann hilft es natürlich.
Dünne Luft, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes, aber genau deswegen ist man ja da.
Dünne Luft, ja wie mit dem Flug. Also es ist ungefähr, die Luftdruckänderung
ist wie beim Interkontinentalflug und so fühlt sich das auch an.
Früher waren die Beobachtungszeiten deutlich länger, aber die europäische Südsternwarte
zum Beispiel hat jetzt ungefähr zwei Wochen Aufenthalt vorgesehen.
Das macht es dann auch sehr angenehm.
Wie fühlt man sich da, wenn man da so ist?
Es ist surreal ein bisschen. Man sieht ein Ozean, weil man schaut ja auf die Wolken.
Es ist, man hat eine Wüstengegend, man hat einen anderen Lichteinfall,
die Dämmerung ist ganz anders und natürlich, wie jeder, ich hätte jetzt gesagt,
astronomische Tourist in gewisser Hinsicht oder astronomische Beobachter,
den Südsternhimmel das erste Mal zu sehen, es fühlt sich immer an wie von einer
anderen Welt, die Magellanschen Wolken zu sehen und dann tatsächlich festzustellen,
dass man mit Fantasie, man weiß, warum sie Wolken heißen, diese Dinge sind dann schon.
Also die Vangelandische Folgen sind ja auch kleine Galaxien,
die man dort mit einem Auge sehen kann, aber nur da oben, ne?
Naja, es kommt drauf an, je nach Wetterlage natürlich.
Ja klar, aber ich meine, sind die Bedingungen erst dort so gut,
dass man die sehen kann oder sind die generell an der Südhalbkugel an einem
klaren Tag zu sehen? Weißt du auch nicht, oder?
Also ich sage mal, in Kapstadt kann ich sagen, dass ich sie nicht gesehen habe,
aber aus anderen Gründen, aber sobald man raus ist, dann sollte man sie sehen
können, denke ich an einem Klaren.
Okay, aber da oben ist einfach nochmal besser, weil es vor allem auch dunkel ist drumherum.
Keine Stadt, keine Lichter und ich denke mal, da ist auch ein hartes Lichtregime.
Das war ein großes Thema, denn die Lichtverschmutzung, Bauprojekte könnten hier
einige Teleskope, je nachdem ob bestimmte Fabriken gebaut werden,
hier eine Rolle spielen.
Und Chile hat eben diesen besonderen Stellenwert als eine der besten Nächte,
die man bekommt, besten, klarsten Nächte, die man bekommen kann mit wenig Wasserdampf
in der Atmosphäre, mit schönen,
nicht turbulenten atmosphärischen Störungen.
Das heißt, Dinge, die man auch mit einem Teleskop gut korrigieren kann,
es tun einige Teleskope und ähnliches.
So, jetzt ist ja dieses Teleskop ein US-amerikanisches Projekt.
Also ist jetzt nicht von der ESO betrieben, sondern wie heißt die Organisation?
Die Geldgeber, das sind die NSF, das ist die amerikanische Forschungsgemeinschaft.
So etwas wie die DFG in den USA. Und der zweite wichtige Geldgeber,
das ist das Department of Energy.
Und die haben eine wissenschaftliche Abteilung.
Und natürlich, es geht hier auch um dunkle Energie. Da sagen wir immer scherzhaft,
deswegen muss natürlich das Department of Energy auch dabei sein.
Aber tatsächlich hat es einen unmittelbaren Bezug auch zum Bau des Detektors.
Die betreiben natürlich und unterstützen natürlich auch die Teilchenphysik.
Und der Detektor wurde tatsächlich in Slack gebaut. Und die haben einen starken
Teilchenphysik-Hintergrund.
Was ist Slack?
Das ist der Standort Linear Accelerator, glaube ich. aber das kann ich dir jetzt
gar nicht wundertproch sagen.
Slack gehört zum Energieministerium, also auch zu diesem Forschungsbereich sozusagen.
Und dort wurde die Kamera tatsächlich, die größte Kamera der Welten mit Pixeln,
was die Pixel angeht, gebaut.
Und dann betrieben wird das von der amerikanischen Universitätsallianz für Astronomie
in ihrem Hauptquartier. und von NoirLab.
Die kümmern sich um die optischen und Infrarot-Teleskope der USA quasi.
So, SLEX steht für.
Standford Linear?
Linear Accelerator Center.
Center, okay. Standford Linear Accelerator Center.
Jetzt weiß ich das selber gerade verwirrt, weil es dann noch Slack National
Accelerator Laboratory auch noch gibt. Also das ist alles ein bisschen durcheinander.
Genau, diese Windung hatte ich eben gerade auch im Gerät.
Also im Prinzip so eine Art amerikanisches Zern.
Ja, ja, ja.
Ähnlich.
Einer von denen, ja.
Ich weiß, die Null ist auch noch weg. Überall wird beschleunigt,
genau. Und deswegen Energieministerium. Okay, und hier haben wir jetzt auch die Finger mit drin.
Warum ist jetzt das ARRI hier mit drin und über welche Konstruktionen ist es mit drin?
Ja, ursprünglich war geplant, internationale Kollaborationen und internationale Partner zu gewinnen,
indem durch Verträge mit jeweiligen Unis oder mit Instituten im Austausch für
Datenrechte diese Beteiligung gesichert wird.
Dann mussten diese beiden Organisationen im Laufe der Umstellung von Finanzen
und von rechtlichen Fragen diese ursprünglichen Verträge zurückziehen.
Und dann wurde eine zweite, eine neue Möglichkeit eröffnet, um doch internationale
Beteiligung zu ermöglichen. Das ist das sogenannte In-Kind-Programm.
Und dieses In-Kind-Programm steht für so eine Art Sachleistung.
Diese Sachleistung kann zum Beispiel Teleskopzeit sein, Rechenzeit oder eben Softwareentwicklung.
Und das ARRI hier am ZAH und das MPIA auf dem Berg, wir haben unabhängige Sachleistungen
eingereicht, um Mitglied oder um die Datenrechte zu erwerben.
Datenrechte bei Rubin sind ein bisschen kompliziert, weil vieles von dem,
was Rubin macht, ist für die Weltöffentlichkeit
und sofort für die Weltöffentlichkeit gemacht und gedacht.
Was jetzt aber...
Bestimmte wissenschaftliche Fragestellungen, die zwei Jahre Frist haben,
um den Leuten, die in den Kollaborationen an den Daten gearbeitet haben,
an den Verfahren, die Möglichkeit zu geben, die auszuwerten.
Per Definition sind alle Amerikaner und alle Chilenen da drin und aus Europa
und auch internationale Partner, die verschiedene Beiträge geleistet haben.
Einige größere Entwicklungen, zum Beispiel in Frankreich, wurde das System für
die Filterwechsel entwickelt und die Speicherung der Daten wird teilweise in Lyon durchgeführt.
Das heißt, die haben über so etwas Zugang und können viele Personen mit Zugang
zu den Daten, das heißt Bilddaten und spezielle Katalogdaten,
die ausgewertet sind, durchgeführt.
Und das ARRI wird dann was genau tun?
Das ARRI wird dann mit den Daten verschiedene Gruppen hier versorgen.
Das sind bei uns, je nachdem wie viel Zeit in diese Sachleistungen geht,
werden bestimmte Betreuer definiert, die dann jeweils vier Studierende oder
frühe Postdocs betreuen, die dann tatsächlich mit den Daten arbeiten.
Das heißt, 32 bis zu 32 Studierende und Postdocs können hier mit den Daten dann
arbeiten, um bestimmte Fragestellungen zu beantworten.
Jetzt bei zum Beispiel mir oder meinem Kollegen, was wäre das denn zum Beispiel,
die Frage nach den Mikrogravitationslösen.
Unsere Direktoren hier zum Beispiel würden nach aktiven galaktischen Kernen
oder nach Sternen, die von gezeigten Kräften eines supermassiven schwarzen Lochs
zerrissen werden suchen.
Oder meine andere Direktorin hier würde nach der Struktur der Milchstraße und
der Entwicklung der Milchstraße suchen und so weiter. Das ist die Idee dabei.
Das heißt, für die Sachleistung kriegen dann unsere Kollegen die Möglichkeit,
mit diesen Daten dann wirklich zu arbeiten.
Arbeitet ihr also sozusagen jetzt auf den Daten nur mit euren eigenen Forschungen
an Forschung oder bietet ihr dann auch im Rahmen des Projekts für andere Forscher
nochmal Dienstleistungen auf diesen Daten an?
Das hängt ein wenig davon ab. Also wir sind jetzt zum ersten Mal bei Rubin ein
bisschen ähnlicher wie die Teilchenphysik organisiert.
Das heißt, wir haben wissenschaftliche Kollaborationen, Rubin,
die verschiedene Wissenschaftsfelder darstellen.
Und bei Rubin geht es nicht nur um die dunkle Energie, dunkle Materiefrage,
sondern es geht zum Beispiel auch um die Struktur der Milchstraße,
es geht um Objekte in unserem Sonnensystem, es geht um überhaupt veränderliche am Himmel,
irgendetwas, was heller und weniger hell wird im Laufe der Zeit.
Und schließlich haben wir noch eine Gruppe, die sich beschäftigt mit nur der
dunklen Energie und ähnlichen oder starken Gravitationslinsen.
Da gibt es auch eine Kollaboration.
Und je nachdem, in welcher Kollaboration wir Mitglied sind, organisieren wir
die Forschung ein bisschen anders.
Das heißt, in unserem Fall für die Mikrogravitationslinsen, wir sind Teil der
transienten und variablen Sterne.
Transient heißt hier nur, wird einmal hell. dann wieder dunkel und bleibt auch so.
Und periodische Veränderliche, die werden immer wieder hell und dunkel und geben
eben Aufschluss zum Beispiel.
Das sind zum Beispiel Standardkerzen, die uns sagen, wie weit ein Stern in der
Milchstraße weg ist oder so etwas.
Und je nachdem, wie das organisiert ist, bieten wir dann in diesen Kollaborationen
auch natürlich Services für Kollegen an.
Und bei unserer In-Kind-Contribution, die ist ein bisschen in diesem System drin.
Das ist ein Softwarebeitrag, das wird ein Webportal, das die bestimmte Events
veränderlicher am Himmel nimmt und bei der Entscheidungsfindung für Weiterbeobachtungen hilft.
Rubin ist zwar in sich eine Entdeckungsmaschine, die veränderlicher am Himmel jede Nacht findet.
Jede Nacht im Prinzip 10 Millionen Punkte, an denen sich etwas tut.
Aber das alleine reicht bei einigen. Und die Zeitauflösung, die wir jetzt mit
Rubin erreichen, also den ganzen Südhimmel alle drei Nächte zu beobachten,
das ist schon spektakulär.
Trotzdem reicht es für einige wissenschaftliche Anwendungen immer noch nicht.
Und dann müssen immer noch Teleskope, robotische Teleskope, wie das Laskubus
Observatory zum Beispiel oder andere Teleskope, auch die ESO,
dann entsprechend diese Ereignisse wieder aufnehmen und für weitere Beobachtungen sorgen.
Und das ist die Idee, dass dann entsprechend die Hilfe bei der Auswahl dieser
Objekte, die macht jede Kollaboration ein bisschen anders und die gestaltet sich auch sehr anders.
Einige Kollaborationen arbeiten extrem eng zusammen und haben einen sehr engen Arbeitsplan.
Einige sind in verschiedenen Kollaborationen überlappend enthalten und das ist
organisatorisch ein Lernprozess, den alle noch durchlaufen müssen, bis das alles so läuft,
wie das in anderen Wissenschaftlern. Bereichen vielleicht der Fall ist.
So, jetzt müssen wir mal aufs Teleskop natürlich selbst kommen,
weil das ist natürlich ein spezielles Ding.
Das haben wir ja erwähnt, es gibt ja schon ganz viele Teleskope,
könnte man ja sagen, ja okay, schon so viel haben.
Wozu brauchst du denn jetzt noch eins? Was unterscheidet jetzt das Vera Rubin
Teleskop von anderen Projekten einerseits?
Ich meine, klar, umso neuer es ist, umso besser ist die Technik und schneller
höher weiter, aber das ist ja nicht der einzige Aspekt hier.
Ja, also jedes Teleskop-Projekt hat eine besondere Nische und einen besonderen Beitrag.
Und bei dem VWC Rubin Observatory und dem Teleskop, was hatte ich vorher nicht
erwähnt, das Simson-Simoni-Teleskop heißt es, ist es tatsächlich so,
dass der Hauptaugenmerk auf der Größe der Kamera liegt und der Größe des Gesichtsfeldes.
Das heißt, mit einer Belichtung nehmen wir einen Bereich am Himmel,
der auf der 45 Vollmonde abdeckt.
Das ist das eine Spektakuläre und das andere ist die Sammelfläche.
Für ein Teleskop der 8 Meter Klasse ist so groß, dass wir eben auch relativ
tief ins Universum schauen können.
Und das hier ist jetzt 8 Meter Klasse, 8,40 Meter glaube ich.
8,4 Meter, genau. Aber die Lichtsammelfläche ist nicht ganz 8,4 Meter,
denn dieses Teleskop folgt einem besonderen Designkonzept.
Damit man dieses besondere Gesichtsfeld erreichen kann, haben wir eine Spiegelfläche,
die zwei unterschiedliche Spiegel beherbergt.
Das heißt, das Licht trifft auf das Teleskop, auf einen Spiegel,
auf einen äußeren Ring von einem Spiegel. Dann wird das Licht nach oben gespiegelt.
Dort befindet sich der Sekundärspiegel und von dort wird es nochmal runtergespiegelt,
aber auf eine andere Fläche des ersten Spiegels sozusagen, weil der eigentlich der dritte Spiegel ist.
Und dann wieder nach oben in die Kamera hinein.
Und dadurch kriegt man die Brennweite von fast zehn Metern zustande.
Und deswegen ist die Lichtsammelfläche nicht ganz so groß, weil der Teil für
den anderen Spiegel muss man noch abziehen, dann sind wir eher bei sechs Meter Klasse.
Aber trotzdem ist das immer noch der Rekord aus diesem Produkt von Gesichtsfeld
und Lichtsammelfläche.
Und dieses Produkt ist das Markenkennzeichen von Rubin.
Und das geht einfach einige Magnituden tiefer als jetzt zum Beispiel das Gaia-Weltraumteleskop.
Und damit entdeckt man natürlich mehr Objekte. Und wenn wir jetzt an Gaia denken,
wir haben hier einen Teil des Gaia-Data-Processing-Teams im Haus und dann denken
wir daran, dann haben wir zwei Milliarden Objekte oder so etwas.
Jetzt geht Rubin noch einige Magnituden tiefer in der Magnitude.
Lichtschwächere Objekte werden sichtbar und dann erreichen wir eben eine Zahl
von 20 Milliarden vielleicht Sternen, vielleicht 17 Milliarden,
wenn man sie wirklich trennen möchte.
20 Milliarden Galaxien. Das heißt, es ist auch ein Durchmusterungsteleskop wie
zum Beispiel Euclid oder Euclid. Das ist auch eine ESA-Mission.
Aber im Vergleich zu dem ist es nicht so hochauflösend.
Aber dafür beobachtet es den ganzen Südhimmel alle drei Nächte.
Und das heißt, wir haben die Zeitauflösung, wir haben die Tiefe und wir haben
das große Gesichtsfeld.
Und diese Dinge zusammen ermöglichen
uns, mehr Objekte zu finden und auch lichtschwächere Objekte zu finden.
Und insbesondere bei den Galaxien zum Beispiel,
ein Datenprodukt wird die, mit verschiedenen Filtern beobachtet man dann entsprechend
die Galaxien, eine fotometrische, das ist die Idee mit Bildern etwas zu messen,
fotometrische Rotverschiebung.
Und das ist etwas, was komplementär ist zum Beispiel zu dem, was Euclid macht.
Und deswegen haben wir hier die Möglichkeit, quasi diese beide Projekte,
die sich auch selbst, sich gegenseitig zu helfen und zu vermitteln.
Ich will das mal ein bisschen sortieren, weil ich glaube, das ist jetzt für
alle, die jetzt hier zuhören, nicht immer so leicht zuzuordnen.
Alte Missionen haben so ein bisschen eine andere, also wir machen ja eigentlich das Gleiche.
Wir gucken jetzt ins All und wir empfangen das Licht und wir speichern das ab und so weiter.
Und je nachdem, an welchem Parameter man dreht, kriegt man halt eine größere
Auflösung, eine größere Beobachtungsfläche,
man kann es schneller machen oder man beleuchtet oder beleuchtet ja nicht,
man nimmt sozusagen das Licht für längere Zeit auf, schaut sehr intensiv, sehr weit.
Ja, wie das zum Beispiel James Webb macht. Er pickt sich halt irgendwelche Sachen
raus und guckt halt so richtig bis ans Ende des sichtbaren Universums.
Aber man kennt das ja so ein bisschen, umso stärker das Fernrohr ist,
umso kleiner ist irgendwie der Ausschnitt.
Und das heißt, so Vergrößerung allein kommt dann immer so mit dem Preis mit,
dann sieht man aber wiederum nicht alles.
Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstanden habe, ist das sozusagen das Rubin-Teleskop
so ein bisschen so ein Kompromiss zwischen all diesen ganzen Parametern mit
einer eigenen Ausrichtung, während Gaia ja vor allem das Ziel hatte,
ich flicke jetzt hier mal, wie viele Jahre waren es jetzt? Vier? Vier Jahre?
Eine Weile, einige Jahre herum, mehrmals mit der Erde um die Sonne und rotiere
die ganze Zeit und mache quasi ein Foto von allem, weil es ging ja darum,
einen Sternenkatalog, primär darum,
einen Sternenkatalog zu entdecken und das er auch macht. Aber.
Rubin ist ja mehr, also es ist ja sozusagen die Beobachtung der Bewegung der
Sterne über einen längeren Zeitraum, um zu wissen,
da ist ein Stern, dich kennen wir und du fliegst mit der und der Geschwindigkeit
in die und die Richtung, weil das haben wir über einen Zeitraum von Jahren beobachtet
und können das entsprechend ableiten.
Tatsächlich ist es auch Teil der Mission, die Bewegung von Sternen,
die Gaia natürlich auch geliefert hat, weiterzufassen.
Aber vor allen Dingen für schwächere Objekte.
Wenn wir uns angucken, wo Gaia gemessen hat, die Helligkeit und die Eigenbewegung,
dann sehen wir eben, dass Rubin noch um einige Magnituden schwächer zu,
sagen wir, bis zu 100 Mal lichtschwächeren Objekten noch entdeckt.
Gleichzeitig hat Gaia einen besonderen Wert, denn wenn die Sterne zu hell sind
und einige von den Objekten, die Gaia beobachtet hat, sind zu hell für Rubin.
Wir haben das Problem, dass wir nicht nur die ganz schwachen Objekte und Veränderungen,
die wir sehen, eventuell nachbeobachten müssen, sondern die helleren.
Wenn ein Ereignis zu hell wird, dann kann es Rubin auch nicht mehr weiter beobachten.
Dann ist der Pixel voll sozusagen.
Das heißt, der Detektor ist dann gesättigt und wir müssen dann auch andere Wege finden.
Aber das Ziel ist sozusagen eine kurzfristige Beobachtung des Himmels,
also eine permanente Abtastung über einen kürzeren Zeitraum,
um zu sehen, ist irgendwo was passiert, weil ich glaube, das ist so eine der
Ziele von diesem Rubin-Teleskop.
Man will halt im Prinzip so eine Art Livestream haben vom Universum und wenn
jetzt irgendwas passiert, irgendwo explodiert irgendwo was und also Dinge werden sichtbar,
dann hilft mir das natürlich nicht, das über einen Zeitraum von vier Jahren
oder so zu beobachten, sondern will man irgendwie am nächsten Tag Bescheid sagen,
hier Leute, da ist was los, richtet mal eure Teleskope aus, los geht's.
Genau. Tatsächlich ist es so, dass wir die meisten Veränderlichen,
dadurch, dass wir so eine Zeitauflösung von drei Tagen haben,
das kann auch Gaia mit dem Scannen,
hat in den seltensten Fällen nur so eine hohe Zeitauflösung hinbekommen und
bei der Größenklasse, also Lichtschwäche der Objekte.
Deswegen ist das die größte Zeitraufferaufnahme des Universums,
wie die Kollegen von Ruben immer sagen.
Und für uns natürlich auch besonders wichtig, weil wir die Veränderlichen am
Himmel finden können. Und zwar 10 Millionen jede Nacht, das ist eben die Zahl.
Also mit Veränderlichen meinst du so Asteroiden, die unterwegs sind?
Alles.
Alles, was sich schnell bewegt, Raumschiffe.
Das Thema lassen wir, aber tatsächlich geht es hier im Wesentlichen darum,
um Sterne, die Ehrlichkeitsänderung von Sternen zu bestimmen und Mikrogravitationslinsenereignisse zu finden.
Aber natürlich auch zum Beispiel die Bewegung von Körpern in unserem Sonnensystem
zu beobachten. Das ist auch eine Veränderung.
Und das Verfahren, mit dem die gefunden werden, das ist diese Differenzbildanalyse.
Man schaut eben lange immer wieder an bestimmte Stellen.
Wenn die Auflösung ein gutes Bild hat, dann passt man das so an,
dass das nächste Datenbild davon gut abgezogen werden kann. und alles, was konstant ist,
Und es bleibt nur noch das Veränderliche übrig. Das ist eine Methode,
die eigentlich auch ganz besonders bei unserem Effekt, beim Mikrolinseneffekt
zum Tragen gekommen ist und die hier das Rückgrat bildet von Rubin,
um diese Alerts, diese 10 Millionen Veränderlichen jede Nacht zu berichten.
Das macht Rubin nicht alleine.
Rubin braucht dafür so eine Art Mittelsorganisation und die nennen wir Broker.
Das hat nichts mit der Börse zu tun, aber hilft uns und der astronomischen und
auch der allgemeinen Community festzustellen, wo verändert sich etwas am Himmel.
Denn nicht, und das ist weltöffentlich, diese Veränderungen werden nur bei gefiltert
nach irgendwelchen Systematiken, dass zum Beispiel irgendeine Cosmic Ray,
irgendeine systematische Störung auf dem Detektor aufgetreten ist.
Aber ansonsten werden die Veränderlichen berichtet in diesem Alert Stream.
Und bei diesen verschiedenen Broker-Teams kann man sich dann einwählen,
zum Beispiel auf deren Homepages.
Größere Länder haben meistens Zentren, in denen das gemacht wurde,
zum Beispiel Antares in den USA ist der Broker für die USA.
Chile hat seinen, der heißt Alerse. Frankreich hat einen, der ist Fink.
Im UK haben wir Alerse in Edinburgh.
Und in Deutschland gibt es auch ein Broker-Team. Es gab einen Wettbewerb,
der ausgeschrieben wurde und dieser Wettbewerb war dazu geeignet,
wer bekommt denn eigentlich von Rubin diese Daten,
weil es ist ein riesiger Schwall an Daten, der verarbeitet werden muss.
Wer ist überhaupt in der Lage, das zu bewerkstelligen?
Und das Team aus Berlin, vom HU und Desi Zeugnis, das ist der Ampel-Broker. Und Jakob Nordin ...
Und Marek Kowalski sind an diesem Projekt beteiligt.
Das heißt, die Kollegen da machen den eben auch und vermitteln eben diese Alert-Streams
in verschiedenen Varianten.
Und jeder von diesen Brokers hat bestimmte Features.
Der hat bestimmte Fähigkeiten, die ein anderer nicht hat. Und der hilft uns
eben zu filtern, an nullter Ebene sozusagen, an erster Stelle,
was ist überhaupt jetzt mal veränderlich.
Kennen wir das schon, denn die Zahl 10 Millionen ist ein bisschen Denn irreführend,
denn bei den 10 Millionen sind bereits die bekannten Variablen mit drin.
Denn Rubin unterscheidet erstmal nicht, ob wir die schon kennen oder nicht.
Das heißt, wenn wir jetzt wissen, okay, jetzt haben wir hier einen bedeckungsveränderlichen
Doppelstern, ein relativ häufiges Objekt oder so etwas,
oder einen Cephiiden, dann ist der da auch noch mit drin.
Und entsprechend annotiert so einen Broker eventuell mit existierenden Katalogen
und sagt, ist schon bekannt oder ist noch unbekannt. Und er versucht mit maschinellem
Lernen und Klassifikation herauszufinden, was ist wohl das Wahrscheinlichste.
Und Wahrscheinlichkeiten werden immer hier angegeben im Sinne von diesem maschinellen
Lernen, wie das trainiert wurde.
Und Broker haben unterschiedliche Klassifikationsalgorithmen laufen.
Und am Ende müssen wir aber eine Entscheidung treffen, was wir beobachten.
Das heißt, wir müssen herausfinden, wie gewichten und wie vermitteln wir über
diese verschiedenen berichteten Klassifikationen. Zum Beispiel,
dass da ist jetzt eine Supernova.
Wie wahrscheinlich ist das, dass das jetzt wirklich eine Supernova ist?
Denn vielleicht fehlen Daten oder wir haben dadurch, dass die Filter sich wechseln,
sind wir uns nicht ganz sicher und ähnliches.
Das heißt, das muss irgendwie quantifiziert werden. Das versuchen wir dann bei
uns in der Sachleistung für diesen
galaktischen Prioritäten oder Wahrscheinlichkeitsmanager, den wir haben,
das versuchen wir herauszufinden, um damit die Beobachtung entsprechend zu kanalisieren.
Das heißt, das muss man ja auch nochmal vielleicht ein bisschen zurückspulen,
also dieses Teleskop liefert ja auch sehr viel Daten.
Allein dieser Sensor in dem Teleskop ist ja relativ groß, 3200 Megapixel,
also für so einen Teil schon ziemlich fett.
Und wie schnell tastet das so ab?
Ja, die 3,2 Milliarden Pixeln sind tatsächlich der Weltrekord.
Und der Weltrekord, die Abtastung ist so, pro Besuch am Himmel,
braucht das Teleskop etwa 30 Sekunden. Und man hat lange überlegt,
wie man die Beobachtung optimiert.
Und das war diese Cadence Optimization, die ich erwähnte.
Und dieses Optimieren hat eben dazu geführt, dass man gesagt hat,
wollen wir eine Belichtung 30 Sekunden oder zwei Belichtungen 15 Sekunden?
Beides hat Vor- und Nachteile.
Da kriegt man noch ein bisschen mehr Rauschen drauf. Aber man kann zum Beispiel
Effekte wie zum Beispiel einen Satelliten, der durch das Bild fällt,
besser verstehen oder entsprechend entfernen.
Das sind ja dann irgendwie 6,4 Gigabyte, habe ich jetzt gerade mal ausgerechnet, ungefähr.
Ja, 20 Terabyte pro Nacht.
Ja, genau.
Und dann sind es 20 Terabyte pro Nacht, zehn Jahre, das sind 60 Petabyte oder sowas in der Art.
Aber jetzt kommt diese Differenzbildanalyse wieder dazu.
Das heißt, man müsste nicht nur die Bilder speichern, sondern auch noch diese
Differenzbilder, weil man dokumentieren muss, wie man eben diese Alerts konstruiert hat.
Deswegen steht da am Ende nicht 60, sondern 600 oder 500 Petabyte im Buch.
Und dann sind wir dann tatsächlich in einer Größenordnung, der ein bisschen
mehr in Richtung andere Wissenschaftsbereiche, Beteiligung und Physik geht.
Also ich glaube, in IT-Fachsprache heißt das eine Menge Holz.
Da ist auf jeden Fall einiges am Start.
Und wenn ich das jetzt richtig verstehe, also die Bilder werden vor Ort natürlich
dann erstmal gespeichert,
dann übertragen und dann geht es von dort aus mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit
zu all diesen Data Brokern, die dann quasi auf diesen Daten ihrer Algorithmen
fahren oder ihre Machine Learning Trainings.
Systeme, wahrscheinlich auch noch in dem Moment natürlich auch immer wieder neu trainieren,
vermutlich, weil das sind ja quasi auch neue Quellen, man muss ja sozusagen
auch mit den Daten erstmal experimentieren und dann fallen quasi überall so
Erkenntnisse raus oder so scheinbare Erkenntnisse oder hier könnte was sein, so Alerts,
wir sagen mal Bescheid, hier hat nicht nur was gezappelt,
sondern Das hat jetzt auf eine Art und Weise gezappelt, dass wir das irgendwie
nicht zurückführen können auf irgendeinen bekannten Himmelskörper oder wir wissen,
da ist einer, aber normalerweise macht er nicht solche Spiräntien.
Das ist sozusagen dann das, was man in der nächsten Stufe erhält und dann gibt
es auch Organisationen, die das mehr oder weniger in Echtzeit auswerten.
Das heißt, wir haben alle drei Minuten sollen, oder innerhalb von Minuten soll
diese, wenn eine Entdeckung gemacht wird, soll die auch tatsächlich bei dem
Broker und bei den Astronomen innen ankommen. Das ist die Idee.
Und die sind dann wie gesagt öffentlich, aber sie sind nicht,
das ist nicht die volle Katalogauswertung, die genaue Auswertung,
sondern die verbessert sich. Es gibt noch etwas.
Diese Bildsubtraktion wird besser, wenn das Template-Bild, was man verwendet, immer besser wird.
Das heißt, wir fangen jetzt mit Rubin an. Das Bild, was man immer als Referenz
im Hintergrund hat, das man anpasst und dem man alle anderen Bilder abzieht,
das sollte immer bessere Qualität haben als das, von dem man das abzieht.
Das ist wie bei Photoshop oder bei irgendeinem anderen Bildbearbeitungsprogramm.
Weichzeichnen ist einfach, scharfzeichnen nicht so sehr. Man zeichnet immer
das schärfste bekannte Bild mit möglichst wenig Hintergrund weich und zieht
es dann von einer passenden Art und Weise ab.
Und dann sieht man besonders gut die veränderlichen und möglichst auch keine
Artefakte oder systematische Effekte.
Und das heißt, es wird immer besser im Laufe der Zeit. Je mehr Template,
je mehr Zufall, wenn man lange beobachtet, hat man immer manchmal auch Glück.
Und dann hat man eine besonders gute Nacht. Und diese Bilder eignen sich besonders
gut, um alle Bilder, die man davor aufgenommen hat, auch nochmal zu verbessern.
Das heißt, es wird ein gradueller Prozess wie dieser Alert-Stream und die berichteten
Alerts besser werden und auch zuverlässiger.
Und dieser Lernprozess und genau das maschinelle Lernen muss sich darauf dann
mit den echten Daten, die ja jetzt hoffnungsvollerweise im Januar kommen werden,
dann entsprechend darauf auch anpassen.
Ich habe, mir ist gerade eingefallen, ich habe mal so hier aus der Filmtechnik
diese Differenzbildtechnik dort auch mal angewandt gesehen,
so wenn man jetzt so Überwachungskameras nimmt und man sieht einfach so ein
Videobild von irgendeiner Landschaft.
Wo sich augenscheinlich nichts tut, aber in dem Moment, wo man diese Differenzmethode
anwendet, die quasi alle Pixel, die sich auch nur so ein bisschen verändern, heller macht,
auf einmal sieht man kleine Hasen irgendwie übers Feld laufen,
die sonst einfach überhaupt nicht aufgefallen wären.
Und ich kann mir das so ähnlich vorstellen, dass auf einmal so dieser super
statisch wirkende Blick auf das Universum auf einmal anfängt,
überall zu zittern und zu zappeln.
Das ist ein sehr schöner Vergleich. Und wir haben vor allen Dingen auch nicht
nur die heller werdenden Objekte sehen wir dort,
sondern auch wenn sich die Position verschiebt, dann sehen wir so eine Art 8,
so eine Art dipolartige Struktur, die dann auch einen Hinweis darauf gibt,
wie schnell die Objekte sich wegbewegen oder wie schnell sich das Objekt bewegt
hat, zum Beispiel Stern oder was auch immer.
Und daraus kann man eben auch wiederum die Eigenbewegung berechnen.
Das soll auch auf diesen Differenzbildern mit genau diesem Ansatz gemacht werden.
Also und das ist ja auch nochmal eine andere Auflösung dieser LSST-Abkürzung.
Ich glaube mittlerweile wird es auf der Webseite.
Legacy Survey of Space and Time heißt das.
Genau, Legacy Survey of Space and Time. Also man schaut sozusagen über die Zeit
hinweg und am Ende sollen glaube ich so an die 30 Billionen Beobachtungen dabei rauskommen.
Also über die prognostizierte Laufzeit dieses Projekts. aber wahrscheinlich
wird das Teleskop sowieso länger laufen.
Das hoffe ich ganz stark. Also zehn Jahre, zehn Jahre ist mehr als fünf Jahre
bei Star Trek schon mal, das ist schon mal gut, aber zehn Jahre ist die Mission
und wir schauen mal, was dabei ist.
Genau. Ja, was verspricht man sich jetzt sozusagen?
Also was soll gefunden werden?
Ein paar Sachen haben wir ja schon gesagt, es gibt so die offensichtlichen Sachen,
so Supernovelle und so weiter, wobei die ja meistens dann,
Also das sind ja glaube ich eher so die Kandidaten, die auch jetzt heute schon
ganz gut gefunden werden,
vielleicht nicht so in die Tiefe, das ist dann quasi eine Erhöhung,
aber generell sind das ja so die Ereignisse, die man gut sehen kann, sagen wir es mal so,
während jetzt so ein Asteroid, der halt durchs All fliegt, in der Regel sehr
dunkel ist und da muss man schon Glück haben, um einen zu finden.
Was sind so andere Dinge, die du jetzt erwartest, die jetzt so passieren werden,
wenn der Datenstrom erstmal loslegt?
Tatsächlich sind die Supernovae noch interessanter, weil wir die an verschiedenen,
viel tiefer im Universum sehen und eventuell Systematiken dort finden.
Wir sagen zwar, Supernovae helfen uns als Standardkerzen herauszufinden,
wie die dunkle Energie die Expansion des Universums antreibt.
Aber wenn wir herausfinden, dass zum Beispiel, woran einige Kollegen vorher
schon sagen, Okay, es gibt aber einen Effekt, der die Helligkeit,
Standardkerzen heißt bei uns, wir wissen ganz genau, wie hell die sein müssen.
Und wenn die scheinbare Helligkeit anders ist, können wir daraus auf die Entfernung zurückschließen.
Wenn jetzt aber systematische Effekte hier eine Rolle spielen,
dass die doch nicht ganz so konstant und Standard sind, wie wir das erwarten,
sondern zum Beispiel eine Abhängigkeit besteht von dem jeweiligen Alter oder
der Entfernung. Dann ist das natürlich auch wieder interessant.
Das heißt, diese Tiefe spielt schon eine Rolle, auch bei Supernovae oder bei,
wie sich diese Veränderlichkeit bei diesen entfernten Objekten verhält.
Also das wäre jetzt, glaube ich, gerade überhaupt so das Thema,
so die kosmologische Krise.
Man weiß nicht genau, wie groß ist denn jetzt das Universum eigentlich oder
wie schnell dehnt es sich aus oder wie alt ist es und es gibt ja verschiedene
Ansätze und alle sind da ganz enorm am Nachrechnen,
aber kommen alle auf andere Zahlen und das wäre ja unter Umständen so ein Faktor,
der dieses Rennen neu aufschlüsseln könnte, oder?
Also zumindest in diesem Fachbereich, also in dem Bereich für die Supernovae,
könnte es sicherlich nochmal interessante Erkenntnisse geben.
Auch hier die Standardkerzen, die man verwendet hat, auch vor einigen Jahren
hat man halt herausgefunden, dass welche verschiedenen Mechanismen zum Tragen
kommen, die die Supernovae eben 1A, Typ 1A, die hier benutzt werden,
wie die zustande kommen.
Das heißt, hier entstehen auch immer noch neue Einsichten und in der Astronomie
aus der Geschichte wissen wir,
wenn wir einen neuen systematischen Effekt bekommen, dann kann so eine,
die Entfernungsleiter, die wir verwenden, um zu großen Entfernungen ihrer Bessung
zu kommen, sich ein bisschen verändern. Das ist ganz spannend.
Aber natürlich den Nobelpreis für die Expansion des Universums, der steht.
Aber trotzdem ein paar Änderungen und ein paar Überraschungen haben wir vielleicht auch hier.
Okay, Supernovae, definitiv ein Thema, weil man jetzt tiefer danach schauen
kann, aber es gibt ja auch noch so andere Ereignisse, die auch sehr kurzfristig
sind, glaube ich, so Gamma Ray Burst, also Gamma Strahlen Ereignisse,
die, wenn ich das so halbwegs richtig mitbekommen habe,
im Wesentlichen von schwarzen Löchern ausgehen oder auch von Neutronenstern,
ich weiß es jetzt nicht so ganz genau, aber definitiv solche Ereignisse sind,
die sehr kurzfristig sind, also die so in galaktischen Dimensionen nicht lange unterwegs sind.
Nehmen wir mal ein anderes Beispiel, nehmen wir mal eine Kilonova.
Also wenn zwei Neutronensterne zusammentreffen.
Genau, da hatten wir zum Beispiel, das nennen wir Multi-Messenger-Events,
das heißt die werden von Gravitationswellendetektoren zum Beispiel entdeckt.
Und hier kehren wir jetzt mit Rubin die Logik um. Normalerweise liefert Rubin Alerts am Himmel.
Aber für solche Events, die nicht gut am Himmel lokalisiert sind,
können wir jetzt die Logik umdrehen.
Ruben, wenn wir mit kleineren Teleskopen versuchen, das optische Gegenstück,
also die Helligkeitsänderung in den Bereichen zu suchen, dann brauchen wir sehr
viel Beobachtungszeit.
Ruben kann hier sehr komfortabel mit dem 10 Quadratgrad Fußabdruck am Himmel
diese Bereiche abrastern.
Und ein kleiner Teil, 3% der Beobachtungszeit, ist tatsächlich bei Ruben für
solche besonderen Ereignisse Neutrino-Quellen vorgesehen, um die entsprechend zu beobachten.
Das war ja hier bei Rumzeit schon mehrfach das Thema. Wir haben uns sowohl die
Gravitationswellen-Astronomie angeschaut,
die ja quasi jetzt so für zehn Jahren begonnen hat und Spoiler-Alert,
ich werde das hier in einer der nächsten Sendungen auch nochmal neu aufgreifen
oder auch dieses Ice Cube,
in der Antarktis, das Neutrino-Messgerät quasi, was da tief ins Eis angelassen ist.
Das sind ja quasi jetzt neue, also komplett andere Signalgeber,
als wir das bisher immer gehabt haben.
Weil wir eigentlich so in der Astronomie primär auf elektromagnetische Wellen,
also Licht aller Art reagiert haben.
Jetzt kommen auf einmal ganz andere Messmethoden dazu, die einem sagen, da passiert gerade was.
Und Gravitationswellen-Astronomie hat ja dann auch schnell durch diese dreidimensionale
Messung so diesen Blick ins Universum und sagt so, ja,
Da ist wahrscheinlich irgendwo gerade was passiert. Könnt ihr da bitte mal hinschauen?
Und dann zählt es ja dann auch weit und schnell, das abtasten zu können.
Und da greift dann das Rubin-Teleskop auch.
Genau, da gibt es einen Katalog, der gerade erstellt wird von wissenschaftlichen Projekten.
Da sind auch noch Supernovae drin, aber ganz sicher auch alle Arten von Gravitationswellenereignissen,
ob es jetzt die Kilonovalde war, die ich angesprochen habe oder ähnliches, aufgegriffen werden.
Der Punkt ist natürlich, wenn man mehr Detektoren hat und das bereits relativ
gut lokalisieren kann, dann ist es vielleicht der Bedarf nicht ganz so groß.
Wenn die Lokalisierung schlechter ist, dann vielleicht entsprechend größer.
Je nach Helligkeit muss man dann schauen, welche Objekte denn dafür in Frage kommen.
Ich weiß tatsächlich, die Kollegen, die mich vor kurzem von den anderen Unis
interviewt haben, haben gefragt, wie man denn eigentlich an diese Zeit kommt.
Und diese Frage muss ich tatsächlich schuldig bleiben.
Ich glaube, das Konzept, wie diese Beobachtungen dann ausgelöst werden,
der ist es noch nicht ganz verstanden.
Okay, aber das sind ja so jetzt diese großen kosmischen Katastrophen,
das sind ja so die richtigen Verkehrsunfälle am Himmel, dein Forschungsgebiet
sind ja jetzt vor allem diese Mikrolinsen, die ja auch eine ganze Menge über
das Universum verraten können,
aber auch das steht natürlich jetzt hier ganz klar im Fokus.
Und was kann man noch rauslesen aus diesem Datenstrom?
Also was wird man voraussichtlich aus diesem Datenstrom?
Was erwartet man, was man aus diesem Datenstrom herauslesen kann?
Ich muss mal ganz genau formulieren, weil wenn ich hier mal sage,
was wird passieren, dann rollen immer alle Wissenschaftler so mit den Augen
und sagen, oh, keiner kann was über die Zukunft sagen.
Kann schon wieder alles morgen anders sein, ich weiß.
Ja, also zumindest die Kollegen aus der Science Collaboration,
Liberation, die sich mit dem Sonnensystem beschäftigt, die hofft eben die Anzahl
an der bekannten Asteroiden deutlich, deutlich auszubauen.
Und bereits in den ersten, im ersten Jahr vielleicht, im Regelbetrieb,
hoffen wir dann schon die bekannte Zahl zu verdoppeln.
Also sind wir schon bei von in großen Ordnung einer auf zwei Millionen und am Ende dann noch...
Und bekannt ist ja auch viel durch Gaia geworden, denke ich mal.
Also es ist ohnehin schon stark angewachsen.
Teilweise, aber tatsächlich ist es, Gaia hat hier ganz besonders in einer Hinsicht
geholfen, um die Vorhersage, wenn
ein Asteroid bedeckt, wenn Bedeckungen stattfinden, Asteroid und Stern.
Da hat Gaia geholfen, die Vorhersagen so viel zu verbessern,
dass die internationalen Teams, die die aufgegriffen haben, eine viel bessere
Chance haben, die aufzufinden.
Früher war das durchaus mühselig. Das weiß ich noch aus meinen Beobachtungsläufen,
einige Objekte dann zu finden oder dann zu beobachten, wenn die Vorhersage nicht ganz gut war.
Durch die Astrometrie von Gaia hat sich das deutlich verbessert.
Und dann haben wir schon hier unsere Rogue-Planets, die hier immer wieder vorbeigeflogen kommen.
Auch die könnten sichtbar werden.
Nein, das ist leider, leider, leider, ich habe da ganz bewusst Nancy Grace Roman
Teleskop dazu gesagt, weil Rubin tatsächlich mit der Abtastung von drei Tagen
nicht zeitlich hoch genug auflöst.
Der Goldstandard für Mikro-Gravitationslinsen in der Größenordnung,
das wären sowas wie 10, 15 Minuten, alle 15 Minuten belichten.
Das kann an einer Stelle für ein Objekt, das macht dann auch Rubin nicht.
Dafür braucht man weitere, andere Teleskope.
Dafür braucht man jetzt tatsächlich Roman, das eine andere Nische quasi hier
besetzt und diesen Bereich abdeckt. Was wir für die Mikrolinsen aus Rubin erwarten,
ist tatsächlich, dass wir nicht nur ins Zentrum der Milchstraße gucken.
Denn Mikrolinsen, die sind statistisch selten im Sinne von, wir müssen im Zentrum
der Milchstraße eine Million Sterne beobachten, um einen davon gelinst,
also verstärkt zu sehen.
Deswegen muss man sehr, sehr viele Sterne beobachten. Deswegen brauchten wir
auch die Differenzanalyse für Microlensing. Und Rubin wird die galaktische Scheibe mehr betrachten.
Da ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit noch geringer. Also 1 zu 10, 1 zu 100 Millionen in Abstufung.
Und entsprechend brauchen wir einfach mehr Objekte zum Beobachten.
Die diese Events auslösen.
Und wir hoffen, dass wir ein besseres Verständnis für Mikrolinsenereignisse
insbesondere quer durch die galaktische Scheibe bekommen in der Milchstraße.
Die großen Durchmusterungen, die immer Mikrolensing- oder Mikrolinsen-Ereignisse
detektieren, werden auch weiter das Zentrum der Milchstraße abrastern.
Das sind in der Regel drei, das sind,
Ogil, das ist das bekannteste polnische Team.
Dann haben wir noch ein koreanisches KMT-Net-Projekt und MOA in Neuseeland und
Japan und in den USA, die entsprechend diese Ereignisse auffinden.
Aber Rubin wird ganz besonders, wird uns neue Möglichkeiten eröffnen,
wie gesagt, die galaktische Scheibe.
Und Mikro-Linsen überhaupt überall am Himmel mit noch deutlich geringerer Wahrscheinlichkeit,
aber doch dort aufzuspüren. und aus der Statistik vielleicht etwas darüber zu
lernen, was für Objekte sind da.
Und wie gesagt, braune Zwerge, wir wissen aus unseren Beobachtungen,
die sind so leuchtschwach, dass wir schon nach wenigen Parsec nicht mehr alle finden.
Da sind ja schon, die Kollegen ja sagen, nach 15 Parsec haben wir nicht mehr alle gefunden.
Microlensing oder der Mikrolinseneffekt ist davon nicht so stark beeinflusst,
weil wir brauchen kein Licht von dem Objekt.
Ebenso isolierte schwarze Löcher. Die hoffen wir auch mit Rubin gut zu finden.
Das Besondere ist, je massereicher ein Objekt ist als Linse,
umso länger dauert es in erster Ordnung.
Es hat noch zwei andere Effekte. Wir brauchen auch Schätzung für die Entfernung
zu Linse und Quelle, die in die Gleichung eingehen und die Eigenbewegung.
Und all dies bei den längeren Events kriegen wir automatisch mit.
Die Parallaxenmessung, die wir brauchen, um Entfernungen von Sternen zu bestimmen
mit Gaia, funktioniert anders als eine Messung von Entfernungen zu Linse und
Quelle beim Microlensing.
Denn wir haben quasi die Linse und wir gucken uns die von zwei Positionen an,
weil die Erde sich um die Sonne dreht oder weil wir noch einen Satelliten haben.
Und die ermöglicht uns nochmal die Entfernung einzuschränken auf diese Art,
weil wir tasten quasi diese Verstärkung am Himmel ab.
Und wenn ich von zwei verschiedenen Seiten durch so eine Weinglaslinse schaue,
dann sehe ich, dass sich das entsprechend ändert.
So, jetzt hatten wir aber schon ursprünglich mal festgehalten,
dass so dunkle Materie vor allem eigentlich ein Ziel auch dieses Teleskops oder
dieses Observatoriums war und wahrscheinlich auch immer noch ist.
Was für Erkenntnisse könnten hier wohl gewonnen werden?
Auch hier sind Gravitationslinsenspiele nicht nur bei uns eine Rolle,
sondern auch auf den großen Skalen.
Das ist jetzt ein Thema, mit dem ich mich nicht beschäftige,
aber der schwache Gravitationslinseneffekt sorgt eben dafür zum Beispiel,
dass die Galaxien, die wir hier in viel größerer Zahl beobachten als mit anderen
Missionen und Teleskopen,
dass diese eine statistische Veränderung der Art der Elliptizität dieser Galaxien,
Aufschluss darüber gibt, wie die dunkle Materie verteilt ist.
Und hier haben wir durch die viel größere Tiefe ein sehr gutes Maß dafür, wie das funktioniert.
Ebenso, wenn wir verstehen wollen, wie klumpig unser Universum ist,
dann müssen wir natürlich weit diese Entfernung bestimmen.
Und da kommt jetzt wieder diese fotometrische Rotverschiebung auch ins Spiel,
die uns hier hilft, diese 3D-Karte vom Universum und diese Art von Struktur
auch weiter entfernt, also,
Länger zurück darzustellen. Und hier schließt sich dann eben die Lücke,
dass man hier noch einmal ein bisschen in der Zeit, aber auch im Raum nochmal
einen neuen Einblick bekommt, um die Theorien, die da sind, zu testen.
Also es ist jetzt nicht unbedingt die Erwartung auf so ein Heureka-Moment,
dass man jetzt irgendwie so eine Beobachtung macht und dann ist alles klar,
sondern es ist halt einfach, es geht immer darum,
weiteres Datenmaterial rein, um einfach Theorien überprüfen und schleifen zu
können und festzustellen, okay, hier, da brauchen wir gar nicht weiter forschen,
aber hier ist unter Umständen noch was zu holen.
Da geht wahrscheinlich noch eine ganze Menge Licht durchs Universum,
bevor wir hier Klarheit haben. Ja, who knows?
Aber einen Tipp willst du jetzt nicht abgeben, was hier noch so an unknowns zu finden ist.
Also Raumschiff hast du schon gesagt, wirst du wahrscheinlich keine geben.
Es ist zumindest nicht die einfachste Erklärung.
Okay, aber du weißt, was ich jetzt fragen muss.
Ich denke, es kommt auf den Planet 9. Ich habe ihn geflissentlich ignoriert,
nicht versucht zu umgehen.
Aber tatsächlich ist es so, dass wir in unserem Sonnensystem sehen,
wenn wir die Anzahl an Objekten im Asteroidengürtel besser verstehen.
Und das hat man auch bei den ersten Bildern gesehen.
Da wurden die Asteroiden tatsächlich für die ersten Bilder rausgenommen und
dann in einem weiteren Bild wieder eingesetzt. Dann sah man da so einen farbigen
Streifen, weil da mit verschiedenen Farbbändern sich sehr schnell durch dieses Bild gegangen sind.
Und wenn man genau hingeschaut hat bei dem First-Look-Event und dem jeweiligen
Video, hat man gesehen, das sind nicht nur Asteroiden, da waren so ein paar
andere Objekte noch drin, jenseits vom Neptun.
Und jenseits vom Neptun haben wir eben Objekte und eine Untergruppe,
zum Beispiel den Kuipergürtel, in dem wir, die durch Rubin einfach auch statistisch
besser beobachtet werden kann.
Und es gab immer Auffälligkeiten in der Struktur, in der Bewegung dieser Objekte,
die Hinweise auf einen droben Bereich geben könnten,
wo eventuell ein Objekt, ein größerer Planet in unserem Sonnensystem sein kann.
Allerdings nicht bei 10, 20, 30 astronomischen Einheiten, sondern eben vielleicht
bei 100 oder 200 oder darüber hinaus.
Genau, also wer das Thema nicht verfolgt, ich weiß, es ist so ein bisschen populär
wissenschaftlich, aber die
Diskussion ist ja on und sie ist in gewisser Hinsicht ja auch spannend.
Also das geht ja hier von diesem Plutojäger aus, wie ist er noch, Mike, irgendwie sowas.
Auf jeden Fall der, der sozusagen den Pluto, seinen Planetenstatus aberkannt hat.
Und der meilt sich die Bewegung in diesem transneptunischen Bereich,
also alles jenseits des letzten uns bekannten Planetens oder von dem wir derzeit
annehmen, dass er der letzte Planet in unserem Sonnensystem ist, dem Neptun.
All diese Objekte, die wir dahinter finden und da gibt es ja einige auch mehr oder weniger Bekannte,
also abgesehen von Pluto natürlich, dann auch Eris und noch so ein paar andere
Objekte und in letzter Zeit sind ja sehr viele dazugekommen,
Bis man ja noch irgendwann gesagt hat, naja, okay, da fliegt jetzt so viel rum.
Deswegen kann man da jetzt nicht einfach mal so ein Planet sein und deswegen
ist ja dann Pluto auch herabgestuft worden und das ja auch aus gutem Grund, wie ich finde.
Und jetzt gibt es diese Diskussion.
Und dass die Beobachtung all dieser ganzen Objekte so ein bisschen nahe legt, Mensch,
das ist aber ein bisschen ungleichmäßig verteilt hier, da kann es ja durchaus
so einen Disruptor geben und daher kommt dann diese Überlegung mit,
ja was wäre, wenn man irgendwie jetzt da noch irgendwo noch einen Planeten hätte,
sehr weit weg, könnte das nicht dieses Bild ergeben,
was wir glauben derzeit zu sehen.
Und diese Suche ist noch offen und ich glaube, die ganze Wissenschaft ist auch,
sagen wir mal, 50-50 gespalten in der Einschätzung, ob das jetzt irgendwie sein kann oder nicht.
Oder vielleicht ist es noch nicht mal 50-50, also es gibt auf jeden Fall eine Menge Zweifler.
Kannst du gleich was dazu sagen? Willst du mal kurz schildern,
wie da so diese ganze Debatte läuft, weil ich finde das auch sehr unterhaltsam.
Und es ist halt einfach auch so diese Frage, okay, wenn es das Ding jetzt gäbe
und man würde jetzt mit dem Teleskop draufhauen, was braucht es eigentlich, um es wirklich zu sehen?
Weil er ist ja nun wirklich deep, deep, deep weit weg.
Also wenn es den wirklich in dieser vorhergesagten Bahn gibt mit irgendwie 240
mal so weit weg wie die Erde von der Sonne, würden wir den überhaupt sehen können
und könnte vielleicht so eine Differenzbildmethode an der Stelle dann auch schon helfen?
Also hier haben wir tatsächlich den Wurzeln von Planet, als Wanderer am Himmel tatsächlich wieder.
Tatsächlich dadurch, dass wir so viel sensitiver mit Rubin sind,
können wir einen viel größeren Bereich bis hundertmal leuchtschwächer absuchen.
Dadurch wird es natürlich, da kommen wir eben in diesen Bereich nicht von ein
paar hundert AU, in denen man dann sagen können und sagen kann,
okay, da ist etwas oder da ist nichts.
Und es ist auch eine wertvolle wissenschaftliche Einsicht zu sagen,
wir haben gesucht, wir sollten darauf empfindlich sein und wir haben nichts gefunden.
Das gilt fast für alle Bereiche. Es ist dann ein bisschen schwierig,
den Wert von Nicht-Entdeckungen bei Empfindlichkeit zu vermitteln.
Weil für uns ist das manchmal sehr spannend.
Warum haben wir das jetzt nicht gesehen? Das ist wie bei Vervority Rubin.
Warum ist jetzt die Rotationskurve der Galaxie nicht so abgeflacht?
Und dieses Abweichen von den Erwartungen ist ja auch eine Erkenntnis.
Bei Planet 9, wenn ein Objekt bis zu der Größenklasse da ist,
dann denke ich, sollte man, der so dicht befestigt.
Dran ist, dann sollte man etwas sehen. Aber,
das unabhängig jetzt von der Differenzbildmethode, die tatsächlich die.
Auswertung für die Asteroiden ist tatsächlich nicht so stark abhängig von der
Differenzbildanalyse, weil die sich so stark bewegen, dass sie tatsächlich noch
ihre eigene Datenauswertung für diesen einen Bereich haben und die etwas anders darstellen.
Weil nach 30 Sekunden sind die schon wieder so weit weg.
Genau. Man muss halt eben diese verschiedenen Punkte zusammenbauen können.
Und wenn wir Wenn wir jetzt sagen, okay, wir wissen aufgrund der Einschläge
auf dem Mond oder so, wie häufig so ein Einschlag von Asteroiden sein kann,
dann kann man jetzt mit Rubin sagen, gut, das ist eine Wahrscheinlichkeit.
Und wenn wir nur eine von sechs Millionen Asteroiden kennen,
dann können wir auch nur Wahrscheinlichkeiten angeben.
Aber die Idee bei Rubin ist, die Bann von diesen Objekten zu haben und tatsächlich
keine statistische, sondern eine eigentliche Vorhersage zu machen.
Das ist auch eine andere Qualität. Aber nochmal zurückzukommen auf Planet 9,
es könnte ja auch sein, dass sich das Sonnensystem, das wissen wir ja auch,
das ändert sich im Laufe der Zeit, dass diese Störung, die man sieht aus der
Änderung der Bahn von Neptun über die Zeit passiert ist.
Oder wir wissen, Pluto ist nicht der einzige Zwergplanet, der seine Bahn,
und das ist ja das Kriterium, nicht so ganz freigeräumt hat,
sondern da haben wir noch andere Objekte, Maki-Maki und so weiter.
Und wir wissen von denen, da gibt es vielleicht auch noch mehr.
Und je nachdem, wie die verteilt sind, werden wir da auch Strukturen sehen.
Tatsächlich, wenn ich, und das ist jetzt tatsächlich mir persönliche Meinung,
wenn ich raten dürfte, ich würde es tatsächlich eher spannend finden oder ich
würde eher erwarten, dass wir noch mehr Zwergplaneten sehen.
Das wäre auch eine sehr schöne Entdeckung.
Und wenn wir keinen weiteren Planeten finden, und das kann schon in den ersten
ein, zwei Jahren passieren, dass man hier etwas ausschließen kann,
dann ist das auch eine wichtige Erkenntnis, dass man nach etwas anderem suchen kann.
Haben wir nicht sowieso einen Observation-Bias insofern, als dass all diese
geilen Teleskope alle jetzt da in Chile stehen,
aber ja eigentlich nur die Südhalbkugel der Erde beobachten können und im Prinzip
50 Prozent des beobachtbaren Universums.
Es ist ja nicht so, dass wir jetzt hier nicht auch nach oben schauen können,
aber diese ganzen super spezialisierten Teleskope haben ja quasi nur die eine Hälfte im Blick.
Kann das sein, dass wir dann sozusagen was verpassen?
Also wir verpassen mit Sicherheit was, aber wir verpassen mal irgendwas Essentielles.
Ja, die Seite, die ist jetzt aber anders als die andere.
Wir haben einen großen Vorteil. Wir
haben das galaktische Zentrum optimal beobachtbar von der Südhalbkugel.
Deswegen haben wir die Teile, die in den Norden gehen und nach Süden gehen,
zumindest für den galaktischen Teil der Forschung, den haben wir da gut abgedeckt.
Wenn man jetzt die gesamte Struktur von der Galaxie untersuchen möchte,
dann wäre es gut, wenn wir auch den nördlichen Bereich haben.
Aber so schnell ein weiteres Teleskop auf der Nordhalbkugel zu bauen, steht nicht an.
Und zehn Jahre Bauzeit heißt, da müssen wir uns keine Gedanken drum machen.
Es gibt vor allem nicht so viele gute Standorte, oder eigentlich?
Gar keinen, der jetzt mit Chile so vergleichbar wäre, oder?
Ja.
Ein bisschen Hawaii. Aber lustigerweise sind die Alpen gar nicht so schlecht.
Nur die Anzahl an klaren Nächten stört hier ein wenig.
Aber ansonsten von den Beobachtungsbedingungen kann manchmal auch ein Teleskop
in den Alpen relativ gute Beobachtungsbedingungen liefern.
Nur eben für diese Art von Durchmusterung ist es vielleicht schwierig.
Ich würde jetzt nicht empfehlen, hier morgen anzufangen, dort ein weiteres Teleskop der Größe aufzubauen.
Aber Hawaii zum Beispiel haben wir oder in Granitikern in La Palma.
Das ist eben auch ein sehr guter Ort. Deswegen wurde ja auch darüber überlegt,
auch noch ein weiteres 30 Meter Teleskop zu machen.
Ich war da oben und da war nur Suppe. Aber das war auch ein Februar.
Dann vielleicht doch die Alpen.
Aber ja, wir haben eine ganz gute, ich glaube, eine ganz gute Abdeckung und
wir dürfen nicht vergessen, wir sehen ja auch noch ein bisschen was auf der
Nordhalbkugel von den Ereignissen und von den Targets.
Wir sehen tatsächlich, das Teleskop wird einige Dinge beobachten,
die auch von der Nordhalbkugel verfolgt werden können.
Viele Amateure hier haben schon gesagt, da haben die Leute auf der Südhalbkugel
jetzt noch bessere Chancen.
Die haben schon die Nase vorn bei allem.
Und ich denke, es wird aber noch genügend Ereignisse und spannende Dinge für
die Amateure auf der Nordhalbkugel geben.
Ja, vielleicht sollen wir zum Schluss auch nochmal über ein anderes Problem
reden, was ja mit dieser ganzen Beobachtung auch fest verknüpft ist,
dass wir also die Lichtverschmutzung ja nicht nur auf der Erde haben,
sondern in zunehmendem Maße auch um die Erde herum.
Die ganzen Megakonstellationen von verschiedenen Satellitennetzwerken,
allen voran natürlich Starlink, aber es ist aber leider nicht das einzige Projekt, was auf der Agenda ist,
tragen natürlich dazu bei, dass Lichtblitze, die wir jetzt hier empfangen,
nicht unbedingt aus fernen Galaxien kommen, sondern unter Umständen aus dem Low-Earth-Orbit.
Wie geht denn die Wissenschaft mittlerweile damit um?
Was ist da so der Stand der Diskussion und konnte das in irgendeiner Form mitigiert werden?
Da gibt es drei Ansätze, die Rubin verfolgen kann und einige davon auch tut.
Zum einen natürlich mit den jeweiligen Herstellern zu reden und einige sind
auch diesen Argumenten entoffen, eine neue Beschichtung,
eine dunklere, ein Limit einzufügen und Tony Tyson quasi der,
sagen wir jetzt mal der Erfinder der
CCD Astronomie, hat da auch ein Paper zugeschrieben und damit verhandelt.
Die Idee ist natürlich schon herauszufinden, ja es wäre gut,
wenn die Konstellationen wie Starlink nicht mit sichtbarem Auge am Himmel zu
sehen wären. Das wäre so eine Maßnahme.
Also dass man jetzt die Dinger einfach entsprechend lackiert,
dass man also Wanta Black drauf macht und wird das getan?
Die Änderung, die Helligkeit der Objekte ist zurückgegangen im Laufe der Zeit.
Das Problem ist bekannt. Ja, aber so einen Satelliten schwarz zu machen,
heißt ja im Prinzip, ihn auch mehr der Aufwärmung auszusetzen.
Genau, wird ihn nicht perfekt, man muss ihn entsprechend vorbereiten.
Der andere Aspekt ist natürlich zu wissen, wo die Satelliten sind.
Beobachtung gegebenenfalls zu planen. Allerdings wissen wir bei Rubin,
naja, wir erwarten, dass bei jedem zehnten Bild etwa mindestens eine Spur von
einem Satelliten enthalten ist.
Das heißt, wir können natürlich dann sagen, deswegen auch vorhin zweimal 15
Sekunden Belichtung hat so einen Vorteil.
Da kann man eventuell den einen Teil, wo man weiß, da ist jetzt ein Satellit
durchgeflogen, die kann man dann
zum Beispiel rausnehmen und das ist dann keine Lört. Das weiß man dann.
Es sind so viele, die werden dann entsprechend korrigiert.
Das heißt, entweder man korrigiert sie in den Bildern Oder man plant Beobachtungen,
wenn extrem helle Satelliten oder andere Möglichkeiten für Energiegewinnung
oder etwas, die deutlich größeren noch Einfluss haben könnten,
Spiegel, die zum Beispiel Licht umlenken, um einen zweiten Mond um Solarzellen
nachts zu betreiben oder so gestartet werden, dann müssen wir darüber nochmal nachdenken.
Weil der Mond hat natürlich auch einen Einfluss auf unsere Beobachtung.
Und zwar im Hintergrund, wenn wir den nicht für die Differenzbildmethode brauchen,
müssen wir den Hintergrund relativ gut verstehen.
Der ist meistens so ein Verlauf und den können wir auch ganz gut modellieren.
Und wenn das nicht funktioniert, dann hat man eventuell hier auch wieder ein Problem.
Aber wie gesagt, das wäre dann tatsächlich etwas, wo wir uns mehr Sorgen machen würden.
Erst einmal mit den Parametern kann man ganz gut arbeiten, die jetzt auf dem Tisch sind.
Wie sich das jetzt in den nächsten Jahren entwickelt und wie Akteure,
die nicht zugänglich sind, zu den Bitten anzunehmen.
Können wir leider nicht beeinflussen. Es gibt da Kommissionen bei der EU,
die sich darum bemühen und auch bei den Vereinten Nationen wurde das,
glaube ich, einmal diskutiert.
Aber ich fürchte, wir werden hier abwarten müssen, was passiert.
Ich glaube nicht, dass wir das als Astronomen lösen, außer unsere Bedenken zu äußern.
Also ich meine so ein Teleskop wie Rubin, was ja eigentlich zum Ziel hat,
wir wollen einen immer größeren Bildausschnitt in immer höherer Geschwindigkeit
abtasten, ist ja kontraproduktiv zu diesem,
wir schicken jetzt auch immer mehr kleine Satelliten raus, die ja nicht nur
eben ein Punkt sind, wenn man 30 Sekunden drauf hält, dann haben die halt auch
schon ordentlich Strecke gemacht.
Nur um mal jetzt so ein Gefühl dafür zu bekommen, in der aktuellen Starlink-Situation,
also mit dem, was jetzt gerade fliegt und man macht jetzt sozusagen ein Bild
mit dem Rubin-Teleskop für diese 30 Sekunden,
mit welcher Wahrscheinlichkeit ist da mindestens ein Satellit drin?
Bei etwa jedem Zehn.
Zehn.
Bei jedem Zehnten Bild erwarten wir mindestens ein.
Mindestens ein, aber es können auch mehrere sein.
Können dann auch mehrere sein, aber derzeit ist das die Schätzung.
Das ist ja eigentlich eine Menge.
Es wird simuliert. Es gibt da
auch eine Gruppe, die sich aktiv damit beschäftigt, auf Seite von Rubin.
Da gab es auch einige Publikationen zu dem Thema. Und,
Wir hoffen, dass es, ich denke, dass es im Moment machbar ist und dass es möglich
ist, das auszugleichen.
Ich bin mir nicht sicher, wenn jetzt zehnmal mehr Objekte da sind und es in
jedem Bild ist und größere Bereiche beeinflusst, solange wir erkennen können,
was das für ein Objekt ist, dass es sich um einen Satelliten handelt, das wäre schon mal gut.
Das hat sich auch verbessert. Anfangs war nicht allen, wenn wir Beobachtungen
von größeren Feldern hatten, nicht klar, ist das jetzt ein Satellit?
Weil die Positionen nicht oder uns nicht genau bekannt waren.
Das hat sich ein bisschen verbessert. Das heißt, dieser Planungsaspekt.
Das hat sich verbessert, weil jetzt die Betreiber, in dem Fall Starlink,
diese Daten dann auch liefern?
Und auch Beobachter Hinweise geben, wo die Satelliten sind.
Das heißt, beides. Es gab dann eine Webseite, die dann angegeben hat,
wo wir ungefähr Starlink-Satelliten finden. Das hilft dann auch schon mal.
Aber es kam nicht selber von Starlink.
Ich weiß es nicht, das kann ich jetzt nicht sagen.
Weil das würde man ja nun erwarten, dass hier zumindest den Bereich,
aber ja, um den Norden...
Ich sag's nicht, da halte ich mich weg.
Nö, in die Luft, ja, ja, ich weiß. Ja, ja, also es ist natürlich mit einer Vervielfachung
dieser Satellitenzahl zu rechnen.
Starlink hat ja noch nicht ansatzweise so viele Satelliten drauf,
wie sie mal gesagt haben.
Uns kommen ja noch mindestens zwei, drei andere Systeme ähnlicher Art dazu.
Plus haben wir ja auch gerade etwas schwierige geopolitische weltweite Auswirkungen,
die ja auch auf die Raumfahrt ihre Auswirkungen haben. Nicht nur was jetzt ISS etc.
Betrifft, aber China zum Beispiel ist ja nicht in demselben Maße eingebunden,
wie das jetzt vielleicht früher unter den klassischen Raumfahrtnationen waren.
So richtig hoffnungsfroh stimmt mich das jetzt nicht.
Weil da geht ja dann doch schon eine ganze Menge Kapazität der Weltraummessung verloren.
Wie gesagt, bei der Anzahl an gestörten Bildern, selbst wenn es noch ein bisschen
weiter nach oben geht, mache ich mir tatsächlich noch für Rubin keine ganz so
großen Sorgen tatsächlich.
Aber jetzt in den nächsten Jahren, für die zehn Jahre, bin ich halbwegs optimistisch.
Was jetzt in den nächsten Jahren passiert, das ist eine Vorhersage über die
Zukunft und Vorhersagen, die die Zukunft betreffen, sind immer schwierig.
Und wenn man gute Daten hat, dann kann man das wagen, aber ich habe hier keine
guten Daten, wie sich das entwickelt.
Okay, ja, ich entlasse dich jetzt aus der schwierigen Fragenklemme.
Ich denke, jetzt haben wir eigentlich alles auch mal ganz gut touchiert.
Gibt es noch irgendwelche Hoffnungen oder Ausblicke, die du mit uns teilen willst?
Wie sieht es vor allem aus?
Wie entwickelt sich dieser Bereich der Astronomie weiter? Also ein künftiges
Teleskop hast du ja schon angesprochen.
Gibt es andere Projekte, die noch so in der Arbeit sind? Wir haben ja immer sehr viel Vorlauf.
Von daher ist ja etwas, was jetzt hier in den nächsten Monaten anfängt,
Daten zu senden, ist ja im Prinzip schon ein alter Hut.
Tatsächlich für uns sind diese Teleskope die beiden wichtigsten Anzeige.
Ecksteine, sage ich mal. Es wird einen weiteren, auch die Entwicklung bei der
Europäischen Südsternwarte für VLTI, das ist Interferometrie und Opte im Optischen,
die Verbesserung wird auch Microlensing helfen.
Ich habe immer gesagt vorhin, wir haben hier quasi Bilder, die sind Millibogensekunden
voneinander getrennt und in dieser größten Skala bewegen wir uns und mit einem
normalen Teleskop, wie bei Rubin, wo so ein Pixel 0,2 Bogensekunden am Himmel ausmacht,
da fällt das komplett runter.
Aber mit dieser Interferometrie gibt es vielversprechende Ansätze,
dass wir eben doch mit der Auflösung bei einigen von den Mikrolinsenereignissen
eine Auflösung erreichen, die hier eine konkrete Antwort gibt.
Dann gab es ein paar Testbeobachtungen und ein paar vielversprechende Projekte
von Kollegen, jetzt nicht von hier, aber aus Polen und aus Harvard.
Und entsprechend hoffen wir, dass dieser Aspekt vielleicht für unsere Methode
noch einmal sehr wichtig sein wird. Und dazu ist für uns immer wichtig,
jede Art von der Gaia-Data-Release, der nächste, ist tatsächlich für uns auch sehr spannend.
Warum? Weil der hat zum ersten Mal zeitaufgelöste Helligkeitsbeobachtungen für
alle Objekte, die enthalten sind dabei und die Astrometrie, also das ist die
eigentliche Messung der Sternposition.
Und die ändert sich bei uns nämlich auch, bei Mikrolinsen, weil die Bilder auch
den Schwerpunkt, den Helligkeitsschwerpunkt verändern.
Das heißt, hier haben wir auch noch Hoffnung, dass selbst, ich gucke eher in
die Zukunft durch die Vergangenheit, dass das nächste Data Release von Gaia,
die Mission ist ja am Leben, und die wird es doch noch viele Jahre sein,
bis alle Daten, jetzt werden ja erst die Daten der letzten,
der normalen Laufzeit, die wir auch vorhin angesprochen haben,
und nicht der Verlängerung, im nächsten Jahr zugänglich gemacht.
Die interessiert uns auch besonders.
Das ist dann das Data Release 4?
Genau.
Ja, irre, ne? Also da fallen so viele Daten an, da kann man noch ein ganzes
Leben lang dran forschen.
Ich hoffe, dass das Rubin-Teleskop für dich auch genug Daten liefert,
um dich hier busy zu halten.
Ja, meine persönliche Hoffnung ist für die nächsten Jahre sicherlich,
dass wir noch mehr Ereignisse, nicht nur zwei, sondern eventuell auch drei Linsen finden.
Das ist meine ganz persönliche Hoffnung, weil wir haben auch mit anderen Methoden.
Zirkumbinäre, das heißt also Doppelsterne mit einem Planet, der die beiden Sterne
umkreist oder ein Doppelsternsystem, wo ein Stern von einem Planeten umkreist
wird, auch mit dem Mikrolinseneffekt gefunden.
Es ist nicht nur ausschließlich in den verheißen Jupiter bei Transits interessant,
sondern eben auch für uns.
Deswegen hoffe ich, dass die bestimmten Kategorien von Ereignissen,
die wir in der Milchstraße sehen, gerade für uns auch ein gutes Master verliefert,
wie viel von diesen Objekten vorhanden ist.
Das heißt, wir verstehen dann ein bisschen besser, wie Sterne in diesem System
und Planeten in diesem System entstehen.
Und vor allen Dingen, wie sie jenseits der Eislinie, das ist das,
was wir besonders verfolgen, machen.
Das heißt, wir suchen ja die ganz kalten und auch felsige Objekte.
Das heißt, diejenigen, die außerhalb von der Wassereislinie in so einem Planetensystem
enthalten sind. Im Gegensatz zu den Transit-Methoden, die ja ganz häufig dicht bei sind.
Und entsprechend hoffen wir, dass wir hier eben auch sehen, wie jetzt die Doppel,
naja, so ein Tatooine-Planet sich bei uns bemerkbar macht. Und ein paar gibt es schon.
Und ich denke, Ruben ist eine gute Gelegenheit, Droman sicherlich auch,
um hier noch viel mehr zu finden.
Also eher zweite Erden ganz weit weg als hier neunter Planet direkt um die Ecke.
Wir sind gespannt, wie es ausgehen wird, das Rennen.
Ja, zweite Erden. Unsere Erden sind M-Sterne. Die Röntgenstrahlung ist ziemlich intensiv.
Da bekommt man mehr als neuen Sonnenbrand.
Okay. Alright, Markus, vielen, vielen Dank für die Ausführungen zum Rubin-Teleskop
und der damit verbundenen Astronomie.
Das war es für mich dann hier erstmal in Heidelberg. Ich bedanke mich sehr fürs
Gespräch und bedanke mich auch fürs Zuhören.
Das war es von Raumzeit. Bald geht es wieder weiter. Ich sage tschüss und bis bald.